is your ex still using your netflix i
know mine
true bill is the new app that helps you
identify and stop paying for
subscriptions that you don't need or
want or you just simply forgot about and
on average people save up to 720 dollars
a year with trubil start canceling today
at truebill.com trash tuesday go right
now truebill.com trash tuesday could
save you thousands a year you guys
30 million women are impacted by
thinning or weakening hair
we
are impacted okay and we love nutrifoal
because it has helped all three of us
tremendously and you can grow thicker
healthier hair and support our show by
going to nutrafull.com
trash get 15 off at nutrifoal.com
spelled n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l.com
trash
hey slugs we had so much fun this
episode can't wait for you to see it
last night was my first episode of my
live spotify show don't bore me with
andy letterman so make sure you don't
miss the next one follow me on social
media and spotify live so you don't miss
it also you can see me live at the end
of the month on the 29th at the vulcan
gas company in austin texas i'm only
going to be there one night so grab your
tickets before they sell out i'll be in
springfield missouri in august and then
in september you can catch me
in pittsburgh tempe
a bunch of other places just go to
andyletterman.com
shows
[Music]
were we obsessed with abercrombie polos
yes okay because i have a ton
abercrombie in general in high school
was like
the the way to go right and i'd always
have this
i would pit out so bad in those polos
because they would just hug your armpits
it was not i don't know if i had i might
have only had one i didn't have that
much abercrombie it was like too
expensive wait did you have a lacoste
polo i remember i saved up and got one
la costa polo aeropostale
that was like the cheaper abercrombie
fit um it was abercrombie when you're on
a
budge not not to like um get molesty in
the first 10 minutes because i know
we're supposed to start wholesome but
the reason i can't look at even the
symbol of aeropostale is because the guy
the counselor who
i i
got you know hooked up with after my
last stint in
um a psychiatric hospital we call him
arapist whole he could not stop wearing
aeropostale
and um every time i see it now that's
the only person that i think about he
was trying to yeah he was trying to
pander to the children
little hollister hollister anyone yeah
that was like budget abercrombie right
but abercrombie owned them and then
there was the other one called it was
actually budget yeah it was like
literally there and then abercrombie
tried to have an even fancier option
which was rule i think
so it was rule and then abercrombie and
then hollister
but it was all the same stuff it was
just a different tag on it um i don't
know if i've ever told esther this but
when i do poses with people at the meet
and greets we do like eat out and then
we always do waffles i go do waffles
rule i don't even know if they know what
it is
waffles rule is from
esther over the pandemic just random
this is before she started smoking weed
just randomly
waffles rule
do you really like waffles
it's most ridiculous i don't even know
why i said it but it was said with so
much passion
like it was so passionate from my gut
from my core like you know when you
speak and it's like it's god is speaking
through you yeah but do you like waffles
i'm not even that much of a waffles girl
but she just had a moment but i'm like
waffles rules they do [ __ ] like they
actually do they cup the butter and the
when you think yes crispy outside
yes
but i said that on a group facetime with
annie and i can't remember if it was
carlos or a friend what just say carlos
but
they both just they
they went at me
now
i actually have
a i'll call it a um
i have an offering today i need an
offering
well actually you're not involved in
this but you
you uh
you will be the witness okay so today i
am going to pay off a debt of annie's
that she may not may not be a friend of
mine but she knows about it and i i am
i'm going to pay off this debt for her
do you have any idea what it is no can i
have clues i want to guess
okay
um
it's something you borrowed from someone
oh i know it okay okay
so
annie
oh my god yes
a few honestly i just saw a strap in
there and i was like if this is a
hanging joke you're the most [ __ ] up
person here
there's a strap i literally was like
lemon belt back honestly all i saw was
the belt i was like oh my god she's a
genius so uh several years ago we lost
one of our dearer friends brody stevens
and someone came out with like this
limited edition hoodie right to
celebrate him and
this is the day
and
carlos ordered one and annie borrowed it
and
i got it so dirty that i couldn't give
it back
however i have had a pristine never been
worn one in my in my closet and i have
decided to pay off your debt wow and
gifted oh my god girls you have to pay
me for it somehow somehow i must make
money off of this
it's such a big deal thank you so it
really is a cute sweater it's so cute
now i feel
like we're in some sort of a financial
triangle
is that why are you trying to get
something from me
well i have something i
for
congratulations on your breakup we're
not gonna let things be dark we're not
gonna let things be dark last week we
were kind of victims and that's okay but
we're not yeah we had our victim moment
we're not victims anymore we're not our
pity party [ __ ] single [ __ ]
single we're celebrating we're not gonna
be sad breakups are always end up being
a good thing always even when they don't
feel like it they always end up being a
pivotal moment but i know you're not
ready to get out there sorry guys
dude i told annie yesterday i think in
like the peak of my sadness or it wasn't
yesterday but i was like i'm just gonna
eat [ __ ] for the rest of my life and
she's like do not say that around esther
do not have that around her
esther's ringing the bell no i'm gonna
be respectful i am in a relationship are
you gonna ring the bell later when you
get home
look i've had thoughts whatever i'm
married almost oh now that it comes
becomes real no it's not real because i
am i'm seeing dave
um
so you know i'm seeing him casually
for 10 years
we're casual we're seeing each other
we're seeing each other passing each
other left and right what i feel
is that what we have to offer you is
that annie and i were born to be wing
women yes it's our good because i'm
i i'm literally like
terrified even stepping out the house so
your first task would be to pry me out
of the house yes no we got to get you
that i'm starting to feel like i'm going
to be able to get you out of the house
honestly and then i i bailed in my boot
barn idea but we gotta go that's a good
start though she said boothbarn listen i
was like
wherever we go will be fun i promise you
that is something i can offer people
i promise you that wherever we go it
will be fun
i think that's a good thing to be able
to offer yeah it is but where it's like
you'll have fun it's like you've had a
heavy blanket over you
okay
you've been going through things you
couldn't express you couldn't talk about
so you could only tell little pieces
that [ __ ] sucks not that you have to
tell but it weighs on you and now
it's time to [ __ ]
rise up but are you do you feel single
yet no okay i think it's gonna be a
while like i'm not kidding you like i
might
like i wasn't kidding when i was like
i'm just gonna eat [ __ ] for the rest of
my life like i'm so uh
pull it out
um
all of a sudden we look over and uh
carlos is like manging
he's talking but this wasn't you know
like for those who don't know like this
hasn't been like it wasn't like an
overnight decision we went into couples
therapy and sometimes couples therapy um
not it just prepares you for the end
yeah and i think that without knowing it
without seeing it for a long time i
think that ultimately that that's what
it was like yeah you did like a
conscious uncoupling i didn't want to
say the word yeah you gotta just say it
guys we're goop we're good
immediately takes legal action
and that's what we would do that's goop
but can we do that instead of chugi it's
like a positive one that's goop yeah
but um yeah i um
it's been uh a lot not a long time but
like the last year it's been in
deliberation it's been on the table
right do we do we not and then you guys
have been privy to that except that
everyone else hasn't been privy to that
so they need to catch up we need to
catch it right right so when like the
whole brendan schaab thing happened he
almost like forced it out of us even
though we weren't ready to talk about it
and we want to thank him for that thank
you so i guess like in in a sense like
you know it that was a blessing in
disguise because it really
like forced us to like tackle head-on
because i think we would have taken much
longer to deliberate
and this sort of pushed it right in the
forefront of our like thoughts and
consciousness um but i
um i'm not kidding you guys like
we've never been closer yeah what well
this is my breakup advice is not gonna
work for this relationship
mine is moved to the other coast
get away from them we're traveling yeah
we're going to the philippines in
september it's like we're more the
pressure of um the label
completely just like dissolved
like
these layers of like resentment and
whatnot it just kind of like went away
and then it went we're back to being
like the peak versions of ourselves
which is like
truly truly obsessed with each other
yeah but not in a romantic way just
simply not in a romantic way but still
like i've always felt that when i met
bobby it was like
i've said this over and over again like
a war comrade like when i met him i was
like i don't need you to give i don't
need to explain to you who i am i get
you you get me it was just like kindred
right and we're back to that we're back
to being able to like communicate
without worrying about like each other's
like feelings so much that's how esther
and i went with our friendship
we had to take the sex out
sex is confusing it really does
confusion i was getting mad at her i was
like but you ate me out last night and
it was at your house one of us still
wants it kind of
i kept showing up late to her house to
get eaten out
okay so i used to watch this japanese
reality show called terrace house and in
terra's house they would do this ritual
like if you're hurting or if you're
going through a transition in your life
they say all of those feelings are in
the tips of your hair
so they would cut they would trim the
tips of their hair i went a different
route and i think annie
no i trimmed my neck i took all of these
skin tags off my neck i can't believe
did you do this yesterday i did this
yesterday you did it yesterday and bobby
got his mole removed too i got my my one
of my for my whole life i had that
moment that's weird i have all these
moles growing all of a sudden i'm just
kidding like i got your guys moles
because we're connected we are don't
grab your tits like they're moles
wait did you take those off yourself no
i have taken them off myself before
using a string don't look at me like
that was not a crazy thing you're like
why would you even that's insane she
burned her neck she said she took them
off i used to i used to have a skin tag
on my eye
with a string to kind of cut the blood
circulation and eventually it just falls
off but that was fun it did
yeah i mean there were days of no health
insurance you know you had to do you
know take matters into take moles into
your own those that health insurance was
okay can i tell you my dermatologist
experience actually because i've never
been like i had
i went to a dermatologist when i was a
teenager
and that's it because i've not had
health insurance until like a year ago
so i go to the dermatologist and this is
how i found my dermatologist this is
very me how i found it i was going to my
tmj doctor and there was just a pretty
woman just walked it's actually very
esther yes a pretty woman who's like i
don't know how old she is but she had
gray hair but her face was like insane
walked into this and i just followed her
in
pushed her up against the no
i followed her in and i was like
can i like i want to get my thing
removed and i look like you and she just
like made me an appointment
and then it was the best offer that is
the most annie story i've ever heard and
i just went in like two weeks later and
i got my mole removed but i've had
forever i've been wanting to get that
removed but you only have like at least
i don't have a pizza neck look at my
neck but i never noticed you had
anything yeah i had to get one removed
back here too and i'm gonna get like
there's a couple more i'm gonna get
removed but they can only do three
uh at a time in my office
did uh so bobby got his mole removed not
because he wanted to was because he was
on h3 with ethan klein and ethan klein's
like dude that thing's cancerous
and i looked at it i was like it doesn't
look cancerous but i was like it is big
so let's get it checked out where is it
it is on his neck okay and so um he got
it removed and the doctor straight up
told him like 99.9
like this isn't cancerous but we're
going to take it out anyways and you
know get it biopsied but no so now he's
like enraged at ethan klein because he
really liked that mole
it was a mole like he was um um he had
feelings for well he's getting rid of
all of his
i'm just like i don't think you had
moles on your neck
i don't recall seeing a skin tag ever
skin tags are a little lighter so
they're not as obvious that she has
chickenpox and she's lying it's like
monkey paws guys this [ __ ] has neck
monkey let me make out with you
i'll give you what i got okay
well this is sim i'm glad you and bobby
i you i'm not worried about but i'm glad
everyone is going the dermatologist we
need to get our skin checked yearly like
skin cancer is a thing you know i try to
get them to give me all the treatments
too i was like what should i get i've
never had anything in my face and they
were like nothing i was like oh my god i
went to an honest dermatologist how
annoying
so i got retinol
like i'm gonna start yeah i'm gonna
start using retinol you yeah you
you don't age it's weird neither do you
it's actually really weird it's actually
so creepy
i'm really sad that i can't get retinol
because i have eczema i don't think if
you guys know anything if you have like
dermatology tips like i've wanted to use
retinol because it'll dry your skin out
it [ __ ] me up like it really causes
like big patches of like isn't that what
it's supposed to do in the beginning
though or no um yeah
it's different like vitamin c i have to
be careful with like certain age
like
age-defying cosmetic stuff i cannot use
because my skin's so sensitive oh that's
cute
i know last week i was like sensitive
skin dude that's joking i don't even
think i don't know my my best friend's
like was very straight to the point and
blunt in terms of breakup advice which i
will ask from you in a second but she
was just like
look she's like um i'm not gonna try and
make you feel better but you're single
now it's not a good time to be ugly so
work out get your get your skin in order
and that's all i have to say and you got
your skin tags for me i got my skin tags
are removed with bobby
popping
you guys can like blow up together
we're getting um he's getting his uh
laser on his face for his liver spots so
we're gonna go to a
appointment together wow he's my he's my
girl now wait i'm like so jealous right
now bobby text her back
that especially but like
i don't know just the thought of like
you sound like you're in like this super
like
co-dependent not in a bad way like you
guys are best buds like i want that
you don't have that with dave
no
do you like dave's like i'm going to
poker i know dave i literally have to
like beg him i'm like can we talk just
like have a chat today and then you have
nothing to say you're like just looking
at them
even one thing that'll make you even
more jealous is that bobby loves to shop
way more than me
and he loves to shop for very expensive
online or out in the everywhere okay
anywhere that he sees something he wants
to go for it so he
he
you know i'm sorry guys i want
i'm excited for you i feel like i am i
identify as like one of like a queen of
platonic female male friendships but
i've never that's a really nice way of
putting that you're ugly
it's so true but i've never had it with
an x i'm wondering like how that is
because like what's it like to like have
your ex invite you over and not just be
like driving by the house not call the
cops on you i mean esther would never
leave
like if you were in a live-in
relationship and they broke up with you
you would just stay liberated i would be
like okay you're gonna squat yeah
get me out go ahead try
i dare you they just pick you up they go
wait i have i i want to ask you guys
like
what are
how do i get through this like what are
some breakups okay for me and everyone
else out there going okay
for me my number one rule is busy busy
busy busy literally fill up that
calendar make plans you have to stay
busy that's all you need oh god what are
you a [ __ ] sucker
i've never
had one of these by the way i spent 500
at the sex shop
yesterday and then immediately we got
tagged by a sex company like do you guys
need toys like on the way over we did i
was like
yeah
being tested by the universe money's
nothing
but i got you i thought this was like a
very regal color for you
there was navy blue white it's weird
it's very american it looks very holy um
and then there was
there was one that was like red red but
i thought this one
wine color for you and then i had to get
you know how
you got to give someone else
that's so cute
you treat me like a baby i got this for
esther here you go
pull it out
what
annie is this a butt plug that would
give me a rabbit yes it was
yes it is wait it's actually so cute
[Music]
i mean it honestly doesn't not look good
it looks so cute
it looks so cute it honestly does and i
think we have our thumbnail
i think we have our thumbnail um
and then i got this what did you get
yourself i got myself just a little
lipstick one oh let me see so i can use
it while we're banging because i don't
i had like a while we're back yes while
we're banging
and then i got these but that i thought
we could play with but i'm going to use
them with
todd was like for me or for you i go
this might not work if you think it
might be for you
this could be the problem
i'm like i should be being [ __ ]
purple choked up against the wall right
now
but i was thinking oh god i haven't
explored like too much like
playful submission stuff and i went to
the store
oh god the thing the
and the girl working there was like
what's cute about our store is
that it's like
it has just like light
s m stuff like if you want to get into
it like light bonded stuff introductory
i was like nobody ever said light
bondage and i think that's why i haven't
tried it because it's always like
hardcore
threatening butt cheeks are tied up are
you keeping really good points yeah like
i'm like i wouldn't let's dip our toes
wait are you keeping that for yourself i
am going to
it's called a hog tie set by the way
i keep falling for the ads where they're
about um
they're like oh
this is a good filter app or something
right like when am i ever gonna use
those and i will download them and then
do the free trial i found out i had
three that were charging me 7.99 a week
a week they were doing a week ones annie
i never used them or looked at them
thank you trouble
well you guys know that i also um
used to pay a lot for an anime
subscription that i didn't know i
already had three of
also i had like an insect finder app
that i had for like six years the
darkest one i've had brain game things
where i thought it was going to make me
a smarter person but it just made me
poor and dumb because i paid a lot of
money every year for many years they
were like
pronounce subscription
you guys companies intentionally make it
really really hard to cancel
subscriptions
and truebill makes it incredibly simple
just link your accounts and truebill
will cancel your unwanted subscriptions
in one tap and your true bell concierge
is there when you need them to cancel
unwanted subscriptions so you don't have
to do it yourself truebill has over 2
million users and helps save them over
100 million i just think it's so easy to
forget and let these things go and
that's why truebill is like one of the
best financial apps that we've ever
discovered because
it just keeps you on top of it and you
don't throw money away for no reason and
even a little bit like like andy said
7.99
a week is absurd i can't believe the
weak ones i didn't know a week i i
should hit you for that a week
you guys on average people save up to
720 dollars a year with drew bill don't
fall for a subscription scam start
canceling today at truebill.com
trash tuesday go right now that's
truebill.com trash tuesday it could save
you thousands a year
back to tips um busy state no idle time
masturbation the thing is masturbating
you're spending so much time with your
ex which is like i don't really know how
to navigate yeah because i would say
usually what i do is like we really find
the worst things about them and we
obviously don't want to do that because
you guys are still
you know partners in so many ways but i
usually what my usual breakup and i'm
good i used to pitch a show
several times never got picked up i used
to pitch it a lot
but about me helping people go through
breakups because you have to villainize
the person even if you don't mean it you
just need to do it for like a month you
have to just find the worst thing about
them so you just break that like
you gotta knock them off whatever
pedestal they're still on oh my god wait
you know what breakup advice my dad gave
me when i went through my horrible hor
you guys know my high school ex who i
drive by his house all the time when he
that was the worst time of my life like
i had never been anything like that like
like food didn't even taste like
anything the dream
i looked really oh my god
my dad was like
he's so dramatic now that i look back
he's like you have to go to their
funeral in your head he's like picture
their funeral you start cracking up
he's like they have to be dead like
there's no contact kind of thing
which but i can't you
is the best way but i'm trying so like
i'm i'm gonna go on a week-long um
spearfishing trip are you already
jealous when she was like a week long
and we weren't invited i don't know what
you want to say but i'm pissed are you
breaking up with me [ __ ] contact with
me
it's just i'm on a boat every day i
don't have a choice but to be nauseous
and go for fish that's perfect um i
don't really have a whole lot of wi-fi
out there there's a whole lot of not not
a lot of communication so i think
that'll be good for me um but um
the whole like keep busy thing
i think in the past i've always done
that and i think it's a good way to um
um if you're really really deep in the
funk
but like you know obviously i've been in
a lot of [ __ ] therapy with bobby on
my own blah blah blah um i um i've never
been able to like sit with my own grief
i've always coped in unhealthy ways i've
never been able to sit with a discomfort
so i'm trying that
i'm trying not to reach for people or
things i'm just trying to like sit with
it get to know this awful feeling in the
pit of my stomach and hopefully like
reconcile with that feeling and say okay
like you live here now
and like just pick it on the lobsters
take care stab those [ __ ] lobsters
and bring them to me i will
it is true you want to feel it because
you always i think like i'm always the
person i feel it so hard and then you
get it out of the way you don't want to
be the person where it's coming up for
months and years i don't want it to come
up six months from now because i didn't
deal with it correctly like it's like i
don't have a problem
ruminating and i think a lot of
when i was dating like
younger men tend to do this a lot or
that's a pattern i've seen where it's
like straight rebound get back on that
horse dude and all the homies are just
like rallying them up and like that's
gonna be so bad for them six months down
the road it's fun now get your dick wet
all of that stuff but
it it's not in any way like healing it's
not so sad like when you [ __ ] someone
that's not the person that you like
wanted to be with or you're used to
being with it's worse it makes things
way worse and it might be exciting the
first time but then it's like empty if
you're not ready that you're right that
hurts is so sad it probably always hurts
with you a little one
but
i am doing something next week that i
wanted to get you guys take on and you
guys know i'm stone cold sober
um i drink alcohol what twice a year the
last time was on my she's stone cold
sober she's her shoulders are stone cold
steve austin
i used to love stone cold i imagine that
is so weird yeah in santa fe
i love him
i love everything i like his life story
everything yeah
how makes me just think of like little
boys in elementary school wwe yeah stop
swishing sliding around
it's nasty oh esther that's never been
my type
but next week i am um doing a
ketamine assisted psychotherapy session
that's 90 minutes long and it's with a
doctor and a therapist and they give you
an intramuscular injection you sit in a
mood pod and you just go through a
journey and i've i'm terrified because i
don't even drink coffee so i don't like
mind-altering things but i think that
i'm i've hit a wall a little bit with
talk therapy and i'm ready to
kind of yeah i don't know what is that
i've only done i've only done outro
muscle ketamine in the pod that is my
tesla
so i don't i think it's going to be
great for you because it's a
disassociative yeah and it so it helps
you be able to look at what's happened
to you without being attached to the
feelings of it
so it helps you and they're going to be
with her to help her so you'll be safe
yeah and they're experts at it and stuff
it's much better than doing it just like
raver style can you compare it to like
an edible high like how is it similar
you feel like you're in a [ __ ] cloud
like it's like everything's very soft
and yeah i don't know
what i have a question though
so this session next week is in
encinitas it's in san diego but
bobby and i are having a day in san
diego too we're driving there together
is that not a good idea what the hell is
this
yeah you got to figure something out
because
it's just going to take longer yeah it's
just going to take longer is the only
issue to be like i understand what
you're doing and i think you guys can
get back to this place
but you are a codependent person so you
have put so much and this is we are not
doing any blamesis here there's no like
negatives or anything you have put all
of your focus on
this crazy funny little whirlwind of a
man
and you are not you have to focus on
yourself
and i don't even think you probably know
what you want
at this point no no
no i'm not out of the freaking merc of
it all what do you want out of what like
what do you want out of the ketamine
experience i want to
um
so um i thought that i had done a lot of
work on myself
um and i'm i was really sort of getting
to a place of like loving myself again
all of that but
when the whole breakup thing happened
and even speaking to you guys i realized
that i have a long way to go
in terms of self-worth there's just i
have my tank is very low
and very common by the way extremely
common it's as someone that studies
hypnotism and stuff almost everything
leads back to self-love and worth and
i'm very insecure and i'm frightened a
lot
um so those are but the the therapist
was like the ketamine will go where it
needs to go so you might have walk in
with an intention of saying these are
the parts that i want to fix she's like
but the ketamine might take you like
somewhere else that's more urgent more
important so you just have to like be
open
so
i don't know we'll see you guys dude i
would i know for a fact it's gonna be
good i would love to like put an
emphasis this summer or whatever like on
building self-worth for all of us like
for our listeners and stuff because
it is kind of like an underrated area to
focus on because whenever i am
really
up on it and making sure that that tank
is full i'm
so much my life is so much better and
it's it takes work i think we're having
a self-worth summer yes i'm 100 down and
mary lou rodriguez my hypnotist is going
to do a group session on us and i
cannot [ __ ] wait i mean
you want a skims endorsement oh we shall
have it
i'm telling you guys this [ __ ] works
like i'm leaning into my goop this
summer too like yeah
like i would so much rather people be
like i'm leaning into my group too i'm
we've all leaned into it accidentally
like oh how do you get on my shoulder
why is it on my forehead
we turn around esther's doing a
handstand
[Laughter]
but i do think that it is like uh
because i feel like it was very
cathartic last week it was really nice
to kind of like
hear you say your piece and stuff but
it's
also i think
like
we're about moving on getting better
healing ourselves
no i'm i'm on board fully on board with
that self-worth is so the key to like a
good life it just really is no it's a
hundred percent yeah it's you have to
have it because our fear our anxiety our
insecurities our feelings of lack of
about ourselves that's where all the bad
[ __ ] comes from and i just do not want
to enter another friendship relationship
until my tank is like
full again because then i'm just going
to resort back to being well then the
[ __ ] will just spill over because your
tank's full also if we're we're
grandfathered in right yeah
your grandfather did
your grandfather
i don't know what that means but we all
realize that it works wait annie i have
a question for you like how do you
how do you decide which mall stay which
moles go
i just like this mole and the other mole
just like was on the corner of my
jawline and it was just like catching
the light it was just [ __ ] annoying
yeah okay but you know what she taught
me that if there's hair in the mall it's
healthy
i thought that was a myth but that's
what my mom has been saying that my
whole life so i don't want to brag but
my [ __ ] does not have cancer
i mean the hair grows mine has a lot
more not cancer than yours my friend
and it's weird because it's per capita
too you guys i haven't waxed in months
and there's still only one hair can i
just show you i know i've shown you my
[ __ ] so many times but like please not
enough honestly maddening to me that i
just have no regrowth when you see mine
there's what a [ __ ] she's like i'm not
ready to date but it won't grow back
that is insane it looks like homers and
carlos has more hair than her [ __ ]
it's like wow i like that it's like i
said that's hot though
it looks like there's supposed to be a
penis there
esther you know laser would work for
that because it's dark
what do you mean laser works better on
dark hair really yeah
kaleila wanna come laser
wait i actually have to read a message
that i got from a slug that is so
awesome so you know how last week we
were talking about like man [ __ ] and
like guys who hook up a lot and you know
whatever like is there a stigma that we
have against them whatever
um okay so this guy damn me and i have
to read it i'm not gonna reveal his
identity and i got his permission
so cool he wrote hi esther just watch
the last pod i used to be a complete man
[ __ ] y'all were right it was extremely
hollow and i never finished
no way no he said no way to word that
where it's not gross sorry i am
extremely glad i was like that i had to
grow up and get out of mice get it that
out of my system and there's no
situation where i would ever cheat now
also the nanosecond i met my now wife i
change and i have never looked at any
other woman the same way and with her
i've never not finished again ill gross
but it's because i needed intimacy love
doesn't hurt that she's the most
beautiful thing of all time also for the
record all my guy friends that watch
tiger belly or tt love kalila oh yeah
sorry
to end on a positive note my wife is
99.9 straight but so gay for all three
of y'all and i got her into tt have a
nice day lady but isn't that cool like
because
i don't think there's any woman who got
through their 20s without
hooking up with a guy
that was using them for sex right yeah
like we've all so it's almost like nice
to hear sometimes you're the guy
i don't remember my [ __ ] 20s but i'm
just saying like
the man [ __ ] are out there and like
they're man [ __ ] with hearts of gold
yeah and it's like nice to hear someone
say like i did that and it was wrong and
it wasn't helpful for me and now he
feels better right but he was saying
that it was helpful for him because he
got through it like he's not that he
doesn't regret it
right right no but i think that's a
that's best case scenario right yeah is
like you know
you're
you just um
you know you you let you allow your dick
to take the lead
when you're young 20 and [ __ ] horny
um and then eventually you learn the
hard way that something is
lacking
and you're you can't come
and so yeah and then you grow from that
that's like a best case scenario
of doing it wrong realizing and then
finding a perfect solution yeah um but
it's not like that any like annie says
it's not like that for a lot of men in
fact you guys are in an industry where
you're around a lot of men that are in
their 40s that still behave that way
yeah who never grow out of it who seem
to think it's sort of like this you know
badge of honor to you know continue to
you know like collect women to just
objectify right well it makes sense
because
you're in a like it's like a rock star
position if you're a comedian like i
feel like comedy used to be
no no let me
because comedy should be like
self-deprecating on this [ __ ]
and then it turned into like i have the
best sneakers i have the best thing and
i [ __ ] dress cute first stage now but
i used to dress like literally like a
troll and go up like
you know same and but it's like comedies
had a new thing where it's like much
more like
yeah and so it kind of makes sense that
a lot of guys who couldn't get
[ __ ] in high school because they like
maybe weren't good looking enough or
confident enough are now have gotten the
skill set that is like attractive to
women
we always like a guy with a sense of
humor so
they can they have a position to like be
more
but that is literally like okay let's
say i grew up and my parents said you
can never have cupcakes and then now i'm
18 and i'm free and it's like i can have
every cupcake i ever wanted it's like
that's sick and sad if i go and eat 12
cupcakes every night she won't even one
bite
that's how i felt about naps i wasn't
allowed to take naps as a child i
remember thinking when i'm
18 and when i have the freedom i'm just
going to sleep all [ __ ] and look at
you now depressed as [ __ ]
can't get out of bed sweaty palms
ripping toilet paper in our hands at all
times paper towel you honestly you
manifested this oh wow
you said i want to take naps as an adult
and you made me
press sluggish
[Laughter]
i watched this tick tock that was like
the it was uh i'll just play the audio
that was really special esther oh yeah
that message
i really really like what he said and
it's very like promising yeah exactly
because i i
like you said a lot of the men
especially in our industry have not had
that growth so it's so meaningful for me
to see a man hear from a man that has
had that growth right right there's hope
all right so this is what i like i like
with this ladies
for this oh yeah an insecure woman will
stir up trouble because she needs to be
the winner
but a secure woman will do nothing
because she knows she wins either way
love that where were you three months
ago
[ __ ] you know what i love most about it
i love to do nothing
more than more than the average gal i'm
sold on the nothing part but also not
like not like in a manipulative way to
like be like i'm not responding to
people or whatever but it is sort of
like if you do start thinking like what
am i fighting for why am i trying to be
right in these situations what do i need
to like who am i trying to win over it's
just ego right you feel the need to like
for victory
somehow because it is a salve to be like
oh i was right there it's a very it's
very it's comforting to the ego yeah but
like you know truly it's like life moves
on wrong or right it just moves forward
it doesn't matter and everyone has a
different interpretation right right
right okay
yes sugar banana in the world
[Music]
[Applause]
my parents like
they literally disagree every single
thing that comes out of one of the
other's mouth the other one is so quick
to disagree like it's and it's so funny
my dad at one point he grabbed my mom's
arm lifted it up he goes she's the
undefeated champion
like because she just kept like getting
her way
and i just see them they're disagreeing
that would throw me into her rage if
someone did that to me if i was trying
to make a point it's so funny it's so
funny
we have a new thing too in my family
which was inspired by my sister which is
we go i i surrender so it's like if
you're ever in a thing it's like you
just go like i surrender oh i like that
it's amazing
we have a lot of tools that come out of
that house
but um
the thing that was so shocking to me so
like literally they're always
disagreeing always like on each other
and everyone let's so and i always say
like it's hard for me because then my
i'm never
my parents are i'm never with them both
happy because one wants to go to this
restaurant the other one oh my god
that's why you think they're not happy
around you
[Music]
the lies we tell ourselves
this is a good self-worth method you
just make up some [ __ ]
wait but then
i had alone time with each of them back
to back like in the morning my mom came
down to the basement before my dad woke
up
and then later when i went on my walk
with my dad and both privately
first my mom goes
your daddy's turning 79 like i don't
know what i'll do without him
i
i
which i'm like oh my parents do that to
me to my mom like i've never lived alone
before
mom
like i can't handle this so thirsty and
then i go
and then when i'm with my dad he's like
i don't know how your mom does all that
she does and i'm like can you guys tell
each other this like they can't so many
people do you have that with you but do
your parents give compliments to your
friends and not you they do to me
your mom would be like i love you yeah
that's so funny
it's like too intense to say it to your
own kid i don't know because
i think yeah i think it's also the same
reason why all of our fans said that i'm
funnier
no my mom remember the night my mom came
to to my like esther and friends show
and we're like who's your favorite she's
like i really liked annie
she's like annie was really funny i did
smash and i did even come out during
your session
my mom is very a physically affectionate
to everybody but my sister and i
so i think that makes sense
it's it's self-worth again
because it's you're her
hmm maybe i gotta there has to be a
study about this because i really look
at her hug other people with so much
envy i'm like wow she really gives great
hugs thank god my mom doesn't give
affection to anybody so i'm good
[Music]
you guys healthier hair doesn't happen
overnight this is why i love neutrophil
it doesn't make overnight promises this
is a product that i use religiously
because when i turned 30 and my i
stopped taking birth control pills i
lost like half of my head
and with neutrophil um it's got really
good ingredients you're basically taking
vitamins for your nails and your hair
and just like your overall health and in
a couple months i swear to you guys i
have seen the difference this isn't
something that um this is something that
i've been taking for years even before
this sponsorship i remember you telling
me about it and you got me turned on to
it neutral what's important about it is
it supports healthy hair growth from
within by targeting the five root causes
of thinning stress hormones environment
nutrition and metabolism and neutrophil
is physician formulated to be
100 drug free that to me is the most
important thing they use medical grade
botanicals in consistently effective
dosages so that you're getting the most
reliable results it's why it works it's
why it's so popular it's why it's one of
our biggest sponsors because people who
get it use it and love it they see
results it just works so well i'm on
like month four of taking it
consistently i had to start getting
these all of these like pill bottles and
putting them in
ahead of time but i take my neutrophil
every day
and it's not just for hair nails it's
for overall well-being including restful
sleep less stress but yes better skin
nails and also libido you guys
[Music]
you can grow thicker healthier hair and
support our show by going to
nutrifort.com trash to save 15 off your
first month subscription this is their
best offer anywhere and it is only
available to us customers for a limited
time plus free shipping on every order
get fifteen dollars off at nutrifoal.com
spelled
n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l.com
trash
my mother once i remember in high school
my mom
was taking my brother's girlfriend who
was obviously going to break up with to
the art museum the photo museum i was
like
i would like to go see hey mom you know
the art skills you pass down to your
true real birth daughter super artistic
i would love to go to that why are you
bringing this [ __ ] that's sucking max's
dick up in his room
this [ __ ] that's [ __ ] got her mouth
filled with our [ __ ] our max's
remember annie the next number the turn
that that story took
it was just so gross and weird like that
my parents like
they weren't very strict but like
definitely
sex was happening in my brother's room
yeah that is interesting is there a
natural inclination for parents to be
less strict with a boy having sex versus
a girl well i don't know one of his
girlfriend's dads came in and [ __ ]
flipped out
was like where are they mom's like
upstairs
yeah like he was like he had no clue
if you sent your kids over to the
letterman's house who knows if they'll
even come back honestly
to pick her up and was like where is she
getting here
getting your back blown up
blown out upstairs
oh my god to a buffy your daughter's
going like this to a buffy got milk
poster oh no and let me tell you she got
milk oh no
no
are we are you going to ask him about
his [ __ ]
i'm going to ask him you're feeling
lucky today
okay cupcakes remember that one time
fox
remember when that girl's dad came
i don't think he was ever allowed to see
her again
i really think that i think that she was
banned from my brother's life after that
gosh you've got to like not forbid
children because they'll double down
yeah find other ways they'll be jerking
each other off under the table you're
sitting at uh-huh
yeah you gotta just that's where the old
hole in the popcorn started let freedom
ring i say
let freedom ring we gotta go to the
movies we gotta take you out i'm gonna
take you on dates
let's go to craigs oh yeah i wouldn't
say little craig's on a breakup we'll do
a breakup tour for you i hate to say
this but i think craig's is overrated
i've never been there i like the food i
have like a great order there that i
love you have to tell me that do you
know what i like i like going on tick
tock and seeing esther with famous
people
i go
do it [ __ ] below our podcast up i have
a request like now my parents have a
request i will allow you guys to take me
to dinner but it's gotta be at kato with
that
it's a restaurant in downtown l.a and
it's probably my most favorite dessert
in my entire life
um so yes that's my request esther will
feed you her kato you're not gonna be
happy why because it's it's kato what's
the food it's expensive oh we are happy
you are crazy you are the only
jew on this
house
out of the two the three people here the
judeas over here
like literally like three percent
i
spend that's where when i spend it's on
food so i'm me too yeah
me when i spend it's on food clothes
travel
my parents
family yeah i love that it's a big money
drainer but yeah my most massive money
drainer is family stuff i gotta say now
that you have more time on your hands
can we get draggy legs the dogs draggy
legs do you know the history of draggy
like yes i know all about this you guys
are obsessed with this dog you found
that has draggy legs but you're the fact
that you're still jealous of the dog is
so crazy still truly actually jealous
not like the camera's not there's no
lying here
that was true like
[ __ ] pissed off that this [ __ ] dog
is taking it it's so funny if we kick
ass drop the podcast and draggy legs is
her replacement
can i tell you guys he just caught me
can i tell you guys that draggy legs is
no longer dragging her legs because i
had um a wheelchair sent to the
philippines and now
she we got you one [ __ ] you sent it
back you sent it back draggy legs got a
wheelchair not a wheelchair the the the
wheels for legs i love a wheels for legs
dog
i love a wheels for legs dog so we can
i'm gonna break
i hate how randy just glides
effortlessly
he is so bouncy and he bounces high he
is so popular guys i i never thought i
would have a dog that's like just out
popularizing me so hard it's like crazy
oh perhaps you're projecting the
jealousy of the dog
i give him a little kick when we go out
no he really is i'm proud of him though
because i take ownership over him you
stupid
[ __ ] he's your baby his spirit is so
pure and happy he's so happy
i'm certainly not projecting that
you're a happy spirit it's in the dick
you gotta dig for it
but um
he
fourth of july we went to my friend's
pool party and people were just staring
at it it was just so funny it's like
look at how he does this and that i was
like you know when you're validated or
like
he is cute
but we went into rite aid the other
night and this girl goes is that
randy yes it is he's like a little local
celebrity
[Music]
i love having my little dog child so
much
i know this seems a kind of random but
i'm really happy right now with a dog
baby yes that is really right for me
right now yes
that and i'll just leave that at that
like i
am really glad i don't have a baby right
now i'll tell you this much like dogs
are a lifesaver during breakups you can
cry right in their bellies and they
don't care and they they like the little
um why does your mouth have to be so
close to the penis and this
collides with back to our old ways
it's hard you're not talking about
there's a dog it's
you have such an attractive mouth it's
really so good i really love your gaps
so much i know we talked about it you
know um they're getting gappier i looked
in the mirror the other day and so now
i'm i actually have gaps on like the
these teeth as well and um yeah is that
good i don't know i don't know why
they're
tongue thrusting what
maybe
tongue thrusting making your palate
wider i don't know guys i gotta go
a lot of jokes here i went and did josh
wolfe had um is shooting a show and i
went and watched him do like a strip
poll
dance with he had a competition with the
sun
and they had this girl nicole the pole
there and she will be teaching me to
twerk so i just want to let you guys
know that will be happening
sometime soon
she was really amazing pole dancers are
[ __ ] rich i would love to do a pole
dancing private lesson with you guys yes
but you're the pole
[Laughter]
well just dancers in general pole or not
they have just but that when she took so
much effort to and core
to keep yourself like steady in that in
that position
it was very
impressive not when joshua ascended it
but when she did it was really
i mean i got props for these [ __ ]
i'll say this if we're going to go out
to like a dinner just to like
yeah exactly you got me
what day
should we just plan it right now
because we always fake but we're going
to do it for real
i've been to two since we've talked
about it esther's been should we bring
her with us on friday yeah are you free
friday night come with us tomorrow night
what are you guys doing party at kesha's
house party cookies
maybe don't say maybe just come she
could say maybe let's see yeah maybe no
we're not we're dragging her remember
how you like to be dragged you're not
the only one likes to be dragged
that sounds fun that sounds fun if i'm
feeling up for it i will text you in the
morning okay we can revisit
yeah
cash is king i don't know how to explain
it i i you know we could always sleep
over there's your energy is oh okay
we go out to eat
we
go to a strip club and then we have a
sleepover yeah
that sounds fun to me we have to
literally we have to wear a machine a
popcorn machine
call i was like we have to do it at
bobby's house though
mommy's coming guys imagine if i did
that
you guys are you okay with bobby
on our breakup
no we shoe bobby away with dave and todd
bobby and dave like went out to eat last
weekend by the way well they went to a
party together
bailed early
bail before i even got there
and then went out to eat went on a
little lover's day i know yeah well they
have like a third friend it's just yeah
it's so interesting it was the third
friend jean hong this guy that it's
dave's poker friend who is like works
with bobby so they're like in this
little friend group wait you know what i
didn't tell you guys last night i had
the most grandma
ice cream flavor
parlenes and cream do you mean prep
i mean pralines what did i call them
parlenes
is that not so grandma though it is very
grandma pralines and why is it grandma
explain to what did i say parliament
parliament
i thought you were trying to say like
maybe marlene i was like that's a
grandma name that's my really name oh it
is yeah
his name is marlene yeah she doesn't
prefer my company
so hang on um so pralines and cream is
just an old school i was removed i was
moved to get it you guys know what i'm
talking about right yeah i totally
identify that as an old lady flavor but
what even is it it's like a vanilla with
caramel and then the nuts the prelims
yeah pralines are covered with
like uh
crusted candies
it's so good oh no i'm an old lady now
wait what are other old lady flavors
pistachio pistachio is an old lady
coffee reminds me my grandfather always
had coffee ice cream that's pretty good
old person flavor
he had after eight minutes do you guys
remember those after eight minutes that
would like come in like the little
sleeves wait so little squares just to
clarify pralines and cream is a it's
ribbons of golden caramel and sweet
nutty praline pecans swirled into
signature vanilla okay that's delicious
what does praline mean
i think that just the way the pecans are
okay oh look she's making fun of me for
not being able to pronounce i think she
doesn't even know what it means
oh it looks like we're both dumb [ __ ]
smooth sweet substance made by boiling
nuts and sugar oh okay
it's so good damn we i've been missing
out on this flavor crunchy it was crunch
it's delicious where'd you get it
ralph's
classy
i thought it was a haagen-dazs
i love a good west side like i i went to
venice like last week i i had to go
somewhere and
i was i love it over there yeah it's
great i was like i can't believe annie
lives here it's so good it's good vibes
it's good all the time yeah venice is
fun and the homeless people have been
there so long i'm sorry the unhome the
unhoused not on people experiencing
homelessness yeah they're not uh unarmed
but they are unharmed housed but um
so scary so stabby
but i find them to be more well versed
in being unhoused
in my neighborhood
because they've just been there for a
long time but you know what that's what
i want to do i want to go to first
fridays in venice
um every first friday they have all the
trucks out okay i didn't even know that
i i knew that i've known that for ten
years yeah yeah so i wanna go first
fridays i wanna bike on the boardwalk or
you can do a scooter or whatever
actually you know what esther i can get
the bike with a little thing yeah yeah
let's get it like actually yes
okay yeah so that way you don't have to
move your legs you could be holding your
dog and doing it because i can't ride a
bike so i would like to participate in
my own i'll drag you in my little you
know euro okay we gotta get one of those
um you know how they have them down the
shore i don't know if you guys know in
jersey where they're like they have a
cover and then it's like
seats of bikes and your whole family can
go on them that's how we'll teach you to
ride a bike oh wait with your arms no
i'm just being the pedal i was like
annie that's so much work
no that is a lot of work but with those
shoulders
i will say i feel safe with those
shoulders i have a little bit of like a
fantasy of because i used to love
rollerblading i would love to
rollerblade at some point if anyone oh i
know that's triggering for your it's not
triggering okay let's try i'm a really
crappy rollerblader but jenna is really
good yeah and she can maybe teach us
yeah jenna i do associate with
rollerblading yeah i need she's very
proud of it too tell her but we i would
love to rollerblade in venice with you
i'm gonna i would like to push you while
you're on rollerblades ugh i would love
that down a hill
that's fine you can catch yourself
i feel like you'd be good at it you're
very coordinated you're a dancer thank
you yeah you're light on your feet where
are you good at when you do it
i don't know for good it was just able
you were the kid like you never broke
your arm at a roller skating party no i
i'm a very fearful careful
kind of
[ __ ] on that i think you are so
coordinated i think that you are a
natural athlete me
she's never gotten positive
reinforcement
she just stops being funny
and i'm happy she just ceases to be
everything oh i was talking to billy
wayne davis who's a comedian
and he was asking me he's like
if you he goes i just would make i would
like to make like 40 million dollars and
then just stop doing comedy would you
stop doing comedy if you made a bunch of
money that has like always been my thing
of like my my dad is always being like
you can tap out like come move in the
basement we can live off your savings
like
that like we can live a frugal life so
that's definitely always been on my mind
but i think i've evolved out of that
thinking lately into like
i love what i do and so it's like i
always want to be doing something and it
might not be making money or whatever
but like
the activity of what we do is
like fun so yeah i don't but i used to
really have that mentality of like i
just want to get in and get out well the
thing is we we weren't making money when
we're done that's true
when you make money it's like less
pressure because we're worrying about
like bills and [ __ ] yeah so the let's
say the the proposition is annie i'm
gonna give you 40 million dollars today
but you can never do stand up i would
never take that yeah i can't there's no
amount i love doing stand up yeah but i
definitely would fantasize about that
like i would look at friends who had
like a five million dollar house and
it'd be like how are they not just
selling that house and moving somewhere
affordable and just [ __ ]
live their lives out but that now i'm
like that's not what i would want no i
would want to keep
going i mean we know a bunch of like
rich people that are not yeah
yeah it's fun it's like cool to connect
with people and stuff like that but you
guys are artists i guess so you know
that's deeply embedded into like your
your constitution so you are as a human
and so it's like i don't think that you
will ever truly be happy and
if you weren't allowed to constantly
express yourself in the way that you
guys have that's true i feel like with
um with stand-up it's like we did i did
it wasn't gonna stop when i was making
no money so why would i stop when i am
making money i know i you know i was
thinking about this the last week like
how we have this show and like we we
make money off of it now and i was like
people probably don't really understand
that especially like annie and i had
been podcasting
for free
for 10 years to no one like we have been
doing it
and stand up every night for like 15 at
most so it's almost like okay we started
this show within a year it's like super
successful but like
we you know this thing like ten thousand
hours is like we have been doing it we
do it we do it we did it for free yeah
so it's like you know we're here because
we wanna be yeah we like right
kala why are you here
um you're the same thing by the way it's
just you were more successful before not
the first couple years you're gonna do
now what do you want to do now the first
years of tiger belly not a scent was
seen okay so your bryce was there in the
beginning
bryce was who hit us up and said hey
what about george kimmel as you get to
produce your show and we had nobody
nothing no ads nothing and i was like
all right and jenna was like what about
gilbert to just press you know gilbert's
from jenna yeah just press play because
bobby and i had recorded our first
podcast it was this amazing two hour one
and then i look over and i hadn't
pressed record
and i was like oh [ __ ] like and so i was
like we need just a person to press
um record
um and i was like hey gilbert do you
know how to press request he was like
yeah and then we spent weeks do you want
to have the greatest easiest job with
the most amount of money ever
hey governor do you want to win the
lottery right now but dude what i didn't
what i found out later was that gilbert
is such a gem because he is such a savvy
business person he also knows a lot of
people he is so well connected he's so
talented and funny and he's so just
lovable like everyone loves him right he
was so funny on the live show he is so
funny yeah he is like the definition of
the kind of guy that like
they really interject like they pick
their spots and they just take the house
down like he's so great naturally yeah
like it never feels like he's trying
that hard he just is so i lucked out
there um but the first couple years were
we were just doing it just to do it we
were like [ __ ] it um bobby's like you
know i'm broke my career is going
nowhere we might as well just do this
and so he did yeah he told me to start a
podcast he was like when i was broke i
was going to pick up my checks in the
comedy store office and bobby was and i
was like oh thank god i got a main room
you know i was like living off of these
yeah and um bobby was like
are you broke and i was like yeah and
he's like start a podcast he's like i
didn't have anything going on before my
podcast yeah i mean obviously had stuff
going on at some point but it's like at
some point but but hollywood that game
where it's like waiting for the next gig
it's horrible
horrible yeah that was a really painful
like that time for bobby when i first
met him i remember he was like
auditioning for an unpaid job to do a
sketch with a kid named hamburger
that was when i knew bobby well when he
was like taking us out to denny's and
stuff and it's like he was not it was
not good right right
and so
i remember going to probably denny's
afterwards because we weren't into the
high-end restaurants in the beginning
um because we didn't have a lot of money
yeah and so um
but we couldn't say that out loud either
we can't say hey like bobby lee's broken
[ __ ] you know but
we he was right we couldn't afford a
bigger home until like years later um
but he was he had auditioned for this
unpaid job and i remember him saying i
need to get this i really need this this
is gonna like change my career and we
always look back at that moment now like
crying hysterically laughing because it
was just such we were like he was he
felt like he was really in the pits and
i remember feeling like i hope you get
it sweetie i really hope and getting on
my hands and knees and saying
god like give this one job with burger
to bobby please and while you're done
and he didn't get it
so it's like yeah podcasting was like
you know it was just a
hail mary but also it was just like what
the [ __ ] else we gonna do
i know but at that point like i had
fully decided i wasn't gonna work as a
nurse and you know at all i was like
[ __ ] that i'm not going that route
if my phone um if my phone gets
disconnected let me suffer is what i
told my mom let me suffer
i need to suffer so that maybe it will
like propel me into really like moving
and feeling some urgency in my life
that's a real thing and that urgency was
going to sam oh you know what do you
call that sam sam ash
oh
um
and getting mics and being like oh [ __ ]
yeah
um and so that's the you know those were
the beginnings they were not fun there's
a lot of things i want to do in my life
and i think that i'm finally feeling
like ready i have been ready for a while
um
but you know when like you don't want to
talk about it until it's already done
right yeah because you almost suck the
juice and the joy out of it if you start
telling everybody about things that you
that haven't when you can't see the
finish line yeah so it's like i hold it
close to my heart these are things that
i'm working on and when it comes you
know to fruition then i'll talk about it
i'm the opposite
only friends only friends all right only
fans dreams dead right
what are our only fans dreams are they
dead i don't think so yeah
i saw something you might have liked i
was at the beach um on saturday and
there was an airplane dragging a sign of
a girl it says onlyfans.com slash and
then her oh i love that good girl
and me and my
friends were like oh my god that's
amazing that's a great [ __ ] move and
all these dads like with their yes
with their kids at the beach just you
know
they're like wiping the sand off
get the sand off that's great burying
their kids like daddy will be right back
so you're gonna work out a bunch and we
can't call it a revenge body because
there's no revenge so we have to call it
a
just friend's body the divorce diet is
not um what's happening to me i've never
been hungrier in my life
that's all i keep wanting to eat
so you know when people are like i'm sad
i can't eat a morsel that has not been
me
at all
okay good i'm hungry that's just hungry
maybe you've been
you know going through it enough that
it's like
you've been starved in many ways
for that [ __ ]
i just i'm not sure i want to see a guy
in like i want to tie him up just not in
that position with the arms behind the
back to the legs to the ankles it's not
it's not a look that i'm into it's like
my plane crush
i know what you're saying like my plane
crush my plane
my dead plane guy
oh right right right here okay so we
stayed friends you know and when i was
single again like i got in a
relationship right after that and then
when we broke up
he we had stayed friends and so he
started to get like a little like oh are
we gonna like hook up again or
and he sent me a sex that was so crazy
he told me he had one of those beds with
um
like bondage hooks on them and i was
like no stranger danger no thank you and
he would send me like porn like this is
the porn i'm watching it was always like
women in ball gags getting like their
[ __ ] whipped i was like i'm not
i would like a regular sex first
and then but then i found the sex he
sent me and he ended up blocking me this
is why
first is such a good rule
i think i was like let's
that's an amazing sentence like you know
regular sex first
i don't i mean i'll bring the purple but
you don't have to make it black
wait let me find it [ __ ] where is it
it's so good
it's just like the craziest that would
be such a red flag for me if a guy was
without me asking yeah being like here's
a porn i'm watching i'm like but it's
just he just was into different things
so this was this was the sex that he
okay read it out loud okay this is what
he blocked me sorry r.i.p by the way
r.i.p nice guy i i would have gone to
the memorial service but i'm respecting
his boundary of blocking me oh that's
smart yeah that's a good rule as well
and it was like i was going for nosy
reasons like i didn't what was i going
to do be like except that's kind of a
cool story to tell i would have gone but
yeah
him blocking you only made you come on
stronger she'd have thrown herself into
the [ __ ] casket you'd be in the
ground with him straddling him
like oh i didn't think this through
one last kiss your dad saves you your
dad saves you he knows exactly where you
are me up throws me in the car all right
so he goes
try to think of me tonight as if we went
to a high school reunion i was like oh
what
and then i'm like everyone's bald and
fat that's what i was thinking
everyone's like bald and fat no thanks
he goes i mean high school prom okay now
we're under age
he goes and then you're all innocent but
then after the prom i take you to this
hotel with its own dungeon i'm like okay
buddy
a dungeon i'm a kid i'm a child i'm in
high school
he goes and you're scared because i miss
my parents you're scared but you stay
and you let me do whatever i want to you
you don't want to like it i'm like no i
don't
i know i was just like how often he goes
but miss them you can't stop yourself
from coming over and over again
especially with the clamps i have on
your nipples i'm like
squeezing out the nipple cheese how did
we get there so fast or the nipple
clamps and then it goes and then and the
vibrator that is strapped in between
your legs that i control with a remote
as i do other things to the rest of your
body now i felt i was asleep when he
sent this and i woke up sucks this he
sucks at sex wait can i just tell you
can i just tell you what i wrote when i
woke up at 6 00 54 a.m i wrote this is
how jean benay died
and he was like [ __ ] you
has he blocked you after that
you are
you're just the one he blocked me after
i posted that
that is so i posted it online
immediately
was so good it's like but you text to
the wrong girl
this you will live forever let me just
tell you there are people who are very
skilled at sexting and people who are
not will never get there and that is an
example of that could never
but
never like even get any blood flow in my
[ __ ] you have to it has to be a girl
that's into that yeah yeah yeah all
right
i don't want to clamp on my nipples yeah
he's just not a match he he needed
someone very different you gotta try
pinching first before you're gonna put a
[ __ ] potato chip clip on my [ __ ]
tip he was very unclear about his
audience is what it was and i was
telling him to i was like i'm not
but he should pass away so we love him
all right p
nothing but right right quiz no look i
do this i do
because of what he did to me oh he did
that to you no oh
i went like this but i didn't do that it
was very it was cute it was just
innocent
we love you quizno boy we really
quiz yes i call him
you guys thank you so much for listening
to this episode this week we will see
you guys next week for a brand new
episode make sure to subscribe and all
as always comment
because
carlos will read them i'm done yeah but
we want to hear from you guys so we love
you come see us live see you next week
[Music]